obviously we're ways in which the
incentives gone had gone completely
haywire for both the lenders and
borrowers to take ridiculous amounts of
risk on the other hand I would worry
that that the reaction is that the u.s.
becomes like Japan that it becomes a
country in which people just invest in
cash and tea bills and maybe five or ten
year government bonds and are taught
that the correct answer is to take zero
risk zero risk works as a business model
for Japan because it's a manufacturing
high-end manufacturing country it does
not work as a business model for the US
what the US does the u.s. is comparative
advantage visa vie other countries in
the world is that it is the place in the
world where people do new things and so
if you get rid of the idea of the
ability to take risk in the u.s. it's
much worse than getting rid of it in
Japan because because if you if you say
that it's no longer gonna be permissible
for people to take any type of risk in
the u.s. then then you basically have no
business model for the US and the US
will lose the global competition even
more badly than it is currently losing
you